[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh buddy let me start with you
how did your dad recruit you
it was a pretty simple uh process i mean
it was more the assistant coaches just
telling me
that i had a scholarship i could could
come play here if i wanted to and
he just one day in the car he's kind of
like uh you know you can play here if
you want to
now it's like all right that's pretty
cool we didn't really say much else and
that's just how it went and
actually you know i'm here so it was a
quick process and uh
just just very happy i'm here any
thought of not playing for your dad
no it was just whether or not i could
come here and contribute and
i think after my junior year they said
you know you can
come here and contribute we need a guy
like you that can shoot the ball
and i said no doubt i never
didn't even think twice about it jim did
you
have any doubts or think twice have
trepidation about
bringing your son in yeah i think so
especially early on he was
you know a good shooter but he had a
long ways to go
but i thought he would get there because
he works
hard i had to convince his mother you
know that
who who runs the family as you well know
uh that would be a good spot for him and
uh
fortunately it has worked out because if
it didn't
then you know the locks would have been
changed at home and uh
there would have been no going back home
as as
as you well know buddy have you ever
complained to mom
about dad um
maybe if he's yelling at my teammates
too much i'll say
you know he needs to relax a little uh
because those are my guys
and uh you know it's tough for me to see
that so
anything like that but yeah he he does
look at me when i
get on somebody and you know which is
good he's supposed to
support his teammates even more than me
so that's that's a good thing
and uh i'm just happy our team is
is really you know stepped up here we
struggled this year there's no question
about that
but they all every guy on this team kept
going
kept believing uh even when it it didn't
look like there was much hope
and you know it's one thing to sneak
into the tournament but
when you get there you have to do
something and uh
this group has really done that and uh
you know those are the teams you like
the teams that just keep going and uh
just don't give up
buddy do you have the green light
uh yeah there's still some times though
when i take a tough one he's like too
far
uh and take your time something like
that but
yeah for the most part which is which is
nice knowing that uh
feels good as a shooter knowing that
that your teammates and coaches have
confidence in you when you have shooters
you let them shoot you know you don't
you don't overcoat shooters they have to
have the
freedom to to let it go and you know
he's
coached by jerry mcnamara who
understands that better than anybody
because he lived it and understands what
shooters
have to do and his teammates really have
confidence in them which
is you know they help him they help them
get shots and
uh that's we just have a really good
team that uh you know wants to win and
wants to do the things you have to do to
win and
it's it's taken us a while but it's
certainly
it's better late than never in this case
buddy the first time you beat your dad
one on one was when
we never really played one-on-one but uh
we have
we played a lot of games against each
other it's more probably me and my
brother that i've had a lot of battles
and
he'll ref our games or something and
we'll yell at him if he makes a bad call
but i used to hate that i used to have
to referee their games and it was brutal
it was absolutely brutal to watch and i
finally said that's it i'm
gone well jim as a 20 year if i had the
20 year old jim behind
against the 20 year old buddy beijing
how would that play out
uh you know i was pretty good i was
better with the ball but he's a
way better shooter than i am buddy why
are you shaking your head
it wouldn't be a game
i've seen it i saw his form when he
played that's all i needed oh they both
think they're much better than me they
think they're better than me on the golf
course and neither one of them can break
50 but they still think they're better
so
it's that's good it's good to be
confident i was looking at your stats
coach
you scored i think 28 points in the ncaa
tournament
in two games but he had 30
against uh san diego state so well he he
didn't have dave bing playing with him
that's true
that's true he also went 13 for 39
but oh
whoa buddy buddy prepared for the
interview
here that is not right those are not the
right facts there i
that should not happen uh take 39
shots in 10 games can we can we check on
that
see what coach uh how many tummy shots
that he had
on the camera it was about
no maybe 12 14 shots
buddy do you imitate your dad oh
man i really can't i mean a lot of a lot
of my team
for past teammates uh even some of the
coaches can do a really good job but
i just let them do it they have some
really good ones and they got his voice
down perfectly and
it's it's funny but it's it's definitely
hard to do
no it's not hard to do buddy it's hard
for you to do it sitting next to your
dad
i always tell people if you watch coach
after a game
i don't know if he's won or lost because
he eventually gets like this buddy
[Laughter]
he just leans over and i
get all the calls nobody i need to have
something for you guys to do
i need to give you material well done
yes mission accomplished uh
have you gotten yelled at buddy yeah i
think
more early on a couple of days in
practice i mean
mistakes are turned over and he'd yell
at me
i think he gets most mad when you make
the same mistake over and over again so
definitely at first but i mean i was
used to i got yelled at
as a kid so this was a little bit
different a little
a little more louder and more intense
but
uh he i want him to yell at me like any
other player
which you know some players they learn
right away and other players it takes
time and
you know some you're still yelling at
when they're seniors but
you know the smart players figure it out
and you know
once they understand what we need to do
um
you don't really have to yell that much
anymore did you
continue to coach did it factor in jim
to be able to coach your son no i mean
i'm happy i'm i'm really grateful to
have this opportunity but no i never
really thought about
not coaching i still haven't thought
about it i plan on
coaching as long as i feel good i think
that
age is i think we've all stopped doing
something that we love to do
too soon and you know i'm not going to
do that
i think about two months ago people
thought it was time to stop coaching but
now they
you know they've come around a late
change of
mind but uh that's part of coaching you
know they're
you're just not gonna please all the
people uh all the time for sure you know
there was that moment after the game and
your wife
sent the picture of you to hugging
and like you're coaching your son
you're playing for your dad you're in
the sweets
like i don't know if it hits you right
then but it seemed to hit you coach
i don't know if it hit you the same way
buddy but you know uh
julie sent it to me and i i mean as a
dad it's like wow that's pretty powerful
stuff
well i know i'm grateful to have this
opportunity
and just just to coach this whole team i
coach buddy
90 percent as a as a player a player on
my team
and then after the game that father part
might take over
and uh but i i've hugged a lot of i hug
carmelo anthony pretty hard
a couple times and i i enjoy hugging a
player and uh but yeah i mean part of
the time
he's he's myself most of the time uh
he's he's
you know he's a player who's you know
doing what we need to get done
yeah but you know what i'm talking about
that that picture is pretty
that that that's a different hug
what was that feeling like though buddy
i don't know if it felt like dad was
hugging me or my coach was hugging me
yeah definitely i mean at first i was
just happy to get the win
and get it over with it was getting
really close at the end so to be able to
just close the game out was a relief
and i saw him i gave him a high five and
i looked back and i'm like i gotta give
him a hug right now
it was just a great moment just all the
emotions uh
he's always supported me been there for
me and this is just a dream come true
so definitely uh just a great moment and
something i'll remember
for forever who's the best shooter on
the team
coaches included that's it's close
i'm gonna go with the underdog here and
go with my man kai feldman
uh he was a walk-on two three years ago
wait he's better than mcnamara
he's he can shoot it i mean that's what
he does he's like he's a
player players players don't know what
they're talking about sometimes
this is one of those times i've been
getting g-mac on the on this trip in our
shooting game so i'm gonna
i mean g-mac can still shoot with the
best of them you know he's right down
over there listening to this
and he's like no no way and coach
explain to me
how joe gerard iii averaged 50 points
his junior year well he was the guy he
took 30 shots a game every game they
needed him
too they had a real small team and
they they just needed him to score 50.
he played against constant double teams
and triple teams and
i don't care what level you're playing
at it's it's hard to score
even 30 points let alone 50 joe
is a scorer he's made the transition to
being a point guard
and he's done a great job uh the other
day and
seven assists he had six rebounds and
you know and he can make shots uh
all of our guards are very important we
have three really great guards
freshmen rich kudari richmond's just a
great player and but
our backcourt is very good and uh
we just got a well-balanced team now and
we've picked up on the defensive end
over the last
three weeks and uh you know north
carolina normally scores 80 against us
i think they scored what 60 something
coach you're giving me coach speak
nobody cares about that i want the juicy
details here like you know has he ever
done a bed check on you buddy has he
ever surprised you to your apartment
is there curfew no no nothing crazy
really just
pretty normal honestly all during high
school he'd go up to bed about 10
30 and i'm like okay you know he just
goes he just would get tired and go to
bed
you know he works so hard dan at this
game that by
10 30 11 he's he's ready to go to bed he
does the extra work here
you know you know obviously he's my son
so i'm proud of that but as a coach
you you respect somebody that has worked
hard
to get there and uh most college
almost all college players work really
hard but you know buddy's
done the extra work to get i told him
he's in ninth grade you're gonna have to
work harder than everybody else to get
there
and uh and he did he listened and and so
i think that's the thing i'm most proud
of is the
the work that he's put in uh
to get there and luckily his mother's
tall
so you know he's got the tall and pretty
too
yeah yeah i mean he he has gets a little
from me in that category so
uh we're very fortunate hopefully you
hold on to your hair buddy
uh i got a clarification on the stats
paulie all right paulie
what do you have here yeah in 1966 uh
jim beiheim in two games versus davidson
and duke
seven for nine from the field six for
ten from the field 13 for 19 in two
games
wow now the facts get out there yes
that's good
that's great yes yeah they got you got
to bring that up with uh
cbs yeah they put that graphic out well
cbs they're
imperfect
[Laughter]
they're not like dan patrick's we have
dan patrick show has the backs
yes yes we got the facts or at least we
know dan can't shoot
oh my god you know better
i might not be able to host a radio show
but i can shoot coach
if you leave me open i will have a
shootout someday then buddy and you
oh no no no that that's not fair
i'd like to see you two go at it um i
i'm like jerry mcnamara with a better
voice
that that would be my i'm like uh
devendorf that i i probably shoot more
like him eric and i probably have a
similar range so is that
good you know gives you a good idea
there buddy eric can still outshoot most
people
yes yes i was going to say mcnamara
against eric
uh would be a pretty good pretty good
matchup i would think
and then the winner gets buddy uh hey
congrats a lot of fun and uh buddy
keep doing it man keep firing yeah we'd
like to talk to you next week maybe
same time okay that sounds good that's
um bring mom too
yeah yeah bringing a whole family of
family i told her she can't come yet
because we're still
because it's she we're gonna we might
lose if she comes so i'm more
superstitious now
well but she texts people during the
game
because she has you know she wants to
talk to somebody yeah she jumps up and
down in front of the tv
and screams at it the whole game too
like a jump ball or something jimmy's
home and he won't sit in the same room
[Laughter]
well congrats great to talk to you again
coach buddy thank you for joining us and
good luck against houston thank you all
right